le deuxième chantier chantier est celui
des mobilités
j'en retenais il travaille ardemment au
sein de région de France et nous sommes
au bord de l'implosion vous le savez
avec 45 euros par habitant et par an
investis sur son réseau la France fait
trois fois moins bien que l'Allemagne ou
la grande buzz Bretagne et je ne parle
même pas de la Suisse où nous sommes 10
fois inférieurs à la Suisse quand la
France prévoit de mettre 2,8 milliards
d'euros par an sur 10 ans l'Allemagne
propose 9 milliards l'Italie 10 et
Jean-Pierre farandoux lui-même chiffre à
100 milliards les besoins à 15 ans nous
devons avoir un plan d'investissement
massif dans les infrastructures
ferroviaires il en va de la souveraineté
de notre pays de la souveraineté bien
sûr par rapport au changement climatique
de la souveraineté par rapport à la
compétitivité économique de nos
entreprises de la souveraineté également
pour relier nos populations et cet
investissement n'est pas une dette
stérile cet investissement
générateur de richesse et bien entendu
de PIB mais aussi de bien-être pour nos
populations
on est donc aujourd'hui pour l'instant
je dirais très loin du compte et la
conséquence c'est que l'état du réseau
ne permet plus de faire rouler des
trains dans de bonnes conditions ni de
rouvrir des lignes nous avons partagé ce
constat avec l'ensemble des présidentes
des présidents de région et si nous
n'agissons pas dans les cinq prochaines
années dans un volume financier
largement décuplé cela veut dire que
d'ici 5 ans c'est près de la moitié des
lignes ferroviaires qui ne pourront plus
fonctionner c'est cela la réalité nous
devons savoir anticiper et je ne
méconnais pas bien sûr la situation
budgétaire de notre pays mais nous
devons porter cet investissement au
niveau européen l'ancien grand plan
d'investissement européen sur les
infrastructures d'un transport et la
France doit être faire de sur ce sujet
c'est absolument indispensable parce que
c'est un investissement je le rappelle
générateur de richesse et la richesse
c'est bien sûr le produit intérieur de
l'autre mais c'est aussi la lutte contre
le réchauffement climatique et c'est
tout simplement que les populations ne
se sentent pas oubliées alors nous
devons bien sûr avancer parce que nous
avons cette question qui est prégnante
et nous devons également revoir le
modèle économique du financement parce
que aujourd'hui SNCF réseau pratique des
péages parmi les plus élevés d'Europe
qui constituent un véritable frein à
l'offre de service à eux seul c'est
péage représente un milliard d'euros et
il faut croire dans son pays il faut
croire dans la nécessité de relier Jean
comme le font les présidents de région
pour développer l'offre de services sur
les lignes ferroviaires parce plus nous
mettons de train et plus nos péages
augmentent
et c'est là ça veut dire que nous
agissons pour la France dans l'équipe
France et donc c'est tout cela qu'il
faut mettre à neuf
nous devons donc également avec ce choc
de l'offre un effort majeur donc sur ces
infrastructures nous devons aussi avoir
une action très forte sur une politique
tarifaire attractive l'Allemagne l'a
fait l'Allemagne l'a fait les résultats
sont puissants trafic en hausse
réduction de la circulation automobile
des millions de tonnes de CO2 en moins
et une atténuation des effets de
l'inflation pour nos concitoyens dans
leur trajet du quotidien depuis le 1er
septembre l'Espagne le fait dans un
rayon environ de 40 km autour des
grandes villes nous devons travailler
sur cette question des transports en
commun sur les territoires denses et
vous en rappelez madame la Première
ministre c'est la proposition des
régions sur l'agence des mobilités sur
les bassins de vie
urbaines nous avons besoin d'avoir une
meilleure complémentarité nous avons
besoin d'avoir un financement partagé
parce qu'aujourd'hui le versement
mobilité de nos entreprises ne
bénéficient en termes clairs pour le
service de transport en commun qu'aux
maximum à deux tiers de le salarié c'est
une question de justice fiscale c'est
une question de réchauffement climatique
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]